[Musique]
dans notre climat les ouvrages en béton
sont malmenés avec le temps des fissures
apparaissent et elles doivent être
réparés voici une approche biologique
étonnante pour régler le problème
[Musique]
ce barrage un centenaire
avec l'usure du temps le béton craque et
se lézarde à cet âge c'est normal ce qui
est surprenant c'est que pour colmater
les fissures on fera t-elle à des
ouvrières invisible des bactéries
notre approche consiste à utiliser des
bactéries qui vont faire le travail de
colmatage à l'intérieur de la future et
qu'ils vont le faire d'une manière plus
efficace que les résine de polyuréthane
automne 2021 centrale de weedon cette
couche de calcite c'est la surface sur
laquelle vivent les bactéries qui
intéresse richard gagné sa quête
commence donc ici avec l'appui d'adrien
terrain doctorants et spécialiste en
microbiologie
donc on prend un coton tige et on vient
faire un frottis pour extraire toute une
gamme de bactéries en apporte une seule
y en a plusieurs on choisit des
bactéries qui vivent déjà dans l'endroit
où on veut intervenir au niveau là sûr
parce qu'elles se sont développés elles
se sont adaptées pour bien se développer
dans cet environnement là qui est un peu
particulier
de retour au laboratoire on sélectionne
les bactéries recueillies sur le terrain
on va les mettre dans un environnement
qui ressemble à celui dans lequel on va
les faire travailler dans la mesure
[Musique]
ce qu'on cherche comme bactéries c'est
des bactéries qui sont capables de
produire de laquelle ces deux-là bio
quel type qui est un petit cristal qui
lorsqu'il est produit à très grande
quantité par les milliards de bactéries
vont s'accumuler dans la voiture pour
pouvoir faire le colmatage
après avoir passé quelques jours dans un
environnement hostile peu d'espèces de
bactéries survivent et celles qui vont y
parvenir joueront différents rôles c'est
comme une équipe de hockey on a des
avants des défenseurs des joueurs de
sang
certains bactéries par exemple vont être
plus efficace en milieu aerobics à dire
lorsqu'elles vont travailler plus à la
surface du béton - en profondeur il ya
plus d'oxygène il ya d'autres bactéries
dans le consortium qu'on va prélever qui
peuvent être anna et robic donc ces
bactéries là vont pouvoir compléter le
travail plus en profondeur à l'intérieur
de leur futur où il ya moins d'oxygène
en parallèle avec ça on va préparer le
milieu d'injection parce que si on prend
ces bactéries là et on les injecte
directement dans une fissure sans rien
faire au préalable elles vont mourir
ça fait un stress énorme pour elles il
faut aussi leur fournir la nourriture
pour qu'elle puisse se multiplier faire
le travail
[Musique]
une fois le travail en laboratoire
compéti on passe aux choses sérieuses
le traitement d'une fissure nécessite
trois heures de travail après avoir
nettoyé la surface on fore des trous
afin d'y insérer la pompe d'injection
[Musique]
on prépare ensuite le liquide à injecter
un mélange d'eau de bactéries et de
poudre nutritive
on a la possibilité de moduler la
viscosité la fluidité du liquide qu'on
injecte pour faire travailler les
bactéries et on peut aller jusqu'à des
fissures d'environ 1 à 2 mm dans ce cas
là on injecte un liquide qui or la
consistance du yaourt assez épais pour
qu'il reste dans la sueur puis pour
qu'il amène beaucoup de nutriments pour
les bactéries
coincé dans la fissure la bactérie
commence alors à se délecter de la cat
de calcium
une fois son repas terminé elle libère
du co2 quand ce gaz entre en contact
avec le calcium une coque en calcaire se
forme autour d'elle à la fin les coques
sont si nombreuses qu'elles finissent
par colmater la fissure
[Musique]
ce processus de cicatrisation et
dynamique c'est à dire que les bactéries
injecté s'adapte à l'évolution de la
fissure
quand les conditions sont défavorables
le processus se ralentit parce que les
bactéries ont moins envie de travailler
sont moins motivés et quand les
conditions deviennent favorables en
termes de température ou d'humidité
parce que ça prend de l'eau pour faire
vivre les bactéries là elles vont
recommencer à travailler de manière plus
plus rapide
si le produit de colmatage classique
agit dès son application
la bio cicatrisation demande quant à
elle un peu plus de temps les bactéries
faut leur laisser le temps de travailler
mais si on leur laisse le temps et on
leur fournit des conditions favorables
on prend les bonnes bactéries elles vont
faire un travail qui est assez
formidable
donc le désavantage c'est que ça prend
pour quelques heures ça prend quelques
jours ou quelques semaines la résine
époxy pelé résine polyuréthane ont des
durées de vie limitée mais nous le
matériau de colmatage la pierre calcaire
et ça ça une ride vie de dizaines
d'années ou de centaines d'années donc
oui le travail est plus là mais on a au
bout de la ligne quelque chose qui pue
père m
richard gagné avait juste la
cicatrisation du béton va au delà de ses
attentes dix ans de travaux dix ans de
recherche qui aurait dit que les
bactéries allait un jour l'aider à
préserver l'étanchéité d'un barrage